man you know those right-wing spin
Meister's you know that the media just
is run by the right-wing 100% I mean
since 2013 when there was a study
showing that a full seven percent of
journalists are registered Republicans
identify as such I've known that the
media has been biased toward Republicans
I mean joy read is I think on this stuff
patently insane she said yesterday by
the way that the Democrats won the
shutdown on on Twitter she said that
they actually manipulated the president
which is a shock
she also said last week that Jeff Flake
the senator who made a speech openly on
the floor of the Senate ripping Trump
was a trumpet so clearly the media bias
extends to joi Reed in favor of
Republicans it's these stats are
ridiculous by the way in the first 100
days according to the Harvard Kennedy
School of Government study the the media
coverage of President Trump was
unprecedented ly bad and negative in
fact networks like CNN and NBC had
negative stories covering the president
outpaced posit was at a thirteen to one
rate CBS covered the president ninety
percent negative in excess of 90 percent
negative that was not rare in the media
so this idea from joy read that somehow
the media was responsible for the
Democrats losing this if the Democrats
were able to lose this political
standoff with the media as heavily
biased toward Democrats as they have
been historically that just shows how
bad the Democrats were this since you
were talking about who in her estimation
won this whole shutdown thing who do you
think won and lost who are the winners
in the losers I mean I was the big loser
here is Chuck Schumer who shut down the
government for no apparent reason
no and nothing out of Mitch McConnell
got nothing out of President Trump and
now we're gonna have to do all this
again in February 8th except for the
fact that the Democrats have no leverage
because they've already shown that
they're not gonna be willing to keep the
government shutdown over any of these
same issues so Schumer is the big loser
here even members of his own party Nancy
Pelosi all the senators and who want to
run in 2020 on the Democratic side been
ripping him up and down I don't think
that that's likely to stop President
Trump obviously is a big winner here he
didn't have to give up anything in order
to get past the government shutdown
Mitch McConnell is is looking more and
more clever by the day over the past
several months not only assuring tax
cuts through the Senate but also
preventing Schumer from continuing to
shut down the government by offering
essentially nothing in return
now the Democrats look like they're in a
fair bit of disarray here which is which
is kind of a shock because you would
have figured that they would have been
unified simply by their hatred of the
president but
apparently there are enough Democrats in
red states who are concerned that they
were going to run competitive races if
they continue to shut down the
government for literally no reason you
travel to all of these states around the
country what are the people in middle
America not the ones that live in New
York not the journalists that live in
California or the swamp in DC what do
they really care about and what is their
impression of what's happening in DC I
mean I think that there's always an
impression that DC is is a hotbed of
stupidity and corruption but I think
that when it comes to things like the
government shutdown I think the vast
majority of Americans forget the coasts
are there the Senate of the country
expense a lot of times I've lived my
entire life on the coast I think the
vast majority of people when there's a
government shutdown aside from the media
headlines about how the world is going
to end and the zombie apocalypse is upon
us most people do not feel it especially
if the government shutdown is only a
couple of days most people look around
they don't see people dying in the
streets and they think in so bad and
then they look at the government being
shut down by Democrats and over illegal
immigration and they say you're really
not gonna send checks to our military
members because you want to protect
illegal immigrants like this is the
Mathew you're doing Democrats realize
that which is why again this thing
passed overwhelmingly among Democrats
right in the Senate vote was 81 votes
completely overall which includes a
which includes about a majority of
Democrats I believe so yeah my thing is
I really could care less about
Republicans who did win this round I
care about them actually getting a
budget done and I care about them
finding a way forward on this impasse so
they gotta find a way forward my sense
is there's a chance the dam broke for
moderate Democrats like Manchin everyone
except tester Heidi Hyde camp and others
they had almost 80 votes for this they
said I'm not gonna let Chuck Schumer
decide my fate and maybe there might be
a sense that they can get something done
if you see a Tom cotton in these
negotiations all you know some of the
people that have stayed out and
criticized on the outside if they get
their hands dirty on the inside with
these so-called moderates we might
actually get something done in three
weeks is there a chance of that Ben I
think there is a chance of that
particularly because the president is
gonna have to stand fast and he has
stood fast so far if he stands fast on
his immigration platform and he says
listen you're not going to get full on
daca is some sort of executive amnesty
enshrined in law unless we also get not
only border security but also a revision
the diversity visa lottery program and
revisions to chain migration and we
actually get some serious immigration
reform here then nothing's gonna happen
and he has the prerogative right he's
the chief executive he could just
continue to not enforce the law the same
way that Obama did so there's really not
a lot of political pressure on the
president's at this point but there is a
lot of political pressure on the left
from the from the from the left side to
the Democrats I think that as so long as
Trump stands fast and he stands with
folks like Tom cotton and yes Stephen
Miller I think that he's going to be
able to get a much better deal out of
Democrats than than skeptics thought
just a few weeks ago Thank You Ben